si vous me suivait depuis longtemps vous
savez que j'aime vous parlez de produits
technologiques on utilise au quotidien
qu'on utilise souvent c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous parle bien
évidemment beaucoup de smartphones
parce que ces produits technologiques
qu'on a toujours avec soi mais il n'ya
pas que le smartphone comme produit
technologique technology est quasiment
de partout elle arrive en tout cas de
plus en plus dans nos foyers
que ce soit pour les éclairages
connectique soit pour les enceintes
intelligente mais dans les objets on
n'aurait pas forcément imaginé et
notamment aujourd'hui ici dans une
brosse à dents oui dans une brosse à
dents une brosse à dents signé ont
relevé c'est toujours d'une vidéo qui a
réalisé en partenariat avec boulanger
qui m'a dit monsieur gros si tu nous
parler de la toute dernière innovation
des toutes dernières innovations de
relever avec une brosse à dents qui est
assez exceptionnel
un produit qui est assez dingue alors
sans principe j'ai d'une brosse à dents
une brosse à dents une procédure sur ma
chaise j'ai regardé j'ai vu le produit
je me suis dit ah ouais ok ah ouais
c'est pas mal je vais donc vous
aujourd'hui vous parler d'une toute
nouvelle brosse à dents c'est une brosse
à dents oral b c'est la série 9 aces et
vous allez voir vous allez voir qu'on a
un truc qui est assez surprenant et je
pense que vous n'allez pas être déçus
mais avant je rentre plus en détail dans
ce produit qui d'ailleurs juste là
j'utilise depuis quelques jours avec
lesquels je me brosse les dents en long
en large et en travers
et bien je vous invite à venir vous
abonner oui bien évidemment pour tout
savoir sans l'activité que ce soit les
smartphones les tablettes ordinateurs et
même des objets pour votre intérieur et
notamment une brosse à dents
c'est une première pour moi mais c'est
une première intéressante vous invite
donc à bien cliqué son petit bouton
rouge qui est situé juste en dessous si
les rouges si vous n'êtes toujours pas
abonné vous actionnez la cloche comme ça
vous serez notifié dès qu une prochaine
vidéo arrivera la technologie est
partout et même parfois de lagon
s'attend pas forcément à venir la
retrouver à savoir dans le soins bucco
dentaire on a donc un produit qui est
assez exceptionnel assez particulier qui
a plein de technologies qui est un objet
connecté il ya une application vous avez
sur ios mais également sur android vous
connecter votre brosse à dents vous
voyez exactement ce qui se passe au
moment où vous venez vous brosser les
dents
vous êtes guidé vous avez un historique
du reporting enfin truc est vraiment
super vous avez des capteurs de tous les
côtés je vais tous vous détailler je
vous montre le produit tu as aidé à vous
en faites alors attendez la boîte je
sais plus comment les sourds je crois
que c'est un truc comme ça y est ce vous
et vous avez votre brosse à dents c'est
très cool objets très précieux on
l'ouvré on vient découvrir ensuite à
l'intérieur le reste alors ça c'est
marrant parce que en fait est une fois
de plus on va pas s'étendre avec une
brosse à dents vous avez des choses qui
sont assez surprenantes
ça c'est son étude transport vous avez
le recharger en induction en transport
jeu montrant quelques instants vous avez
la ligne principale pour la maison vous
le recharger en induction sans fil
sophie ça c'est marrant c'est très très
cool bien évidemment on à la brossette y
compris dans qu'on peut venir à
interchanger pour des questions
d'hygiène et d'usure cette brosse à
dents elle est assez surprenante parce
qu'effectivement elle vous nettoyez dans
toute seule et puis surtout parce que
les deux minutes voire les trois minutes
vous les voyez pas passer parce qu'on a
un côté très ludique avec l'application
alors avant de vous parler de
l'application je veux montrer le produit
comment il fonctionne très bien
déjà elle commence par vous diront
autour ça c'est une brosse à dents
qu'est police est très très couleur vous
avez plusieurs mois nous avons tous
cette mode
le mode pour le nettoyage quotidien pour
les dents sensibles pour rendre les
dents plus blanches si vous le souhaitez
pour enlever du tartre un nettoyage très
intense si vraiment vous êtes hyper
sensible ou aussi pour venir vous
nettoyez la langue parce que oui votre
langue
il faut aussi à nettoyer quelques petits
paramètres et puis on revient ici au
début un bouton pour me relancer
nettoyage et un nouveau pont bien
naviguer très simple vous n'allez pas y
échapper dans quelques instants je vais
vous emmener avec moi à la maison dans
la salle de bain vous montrer exactement
se produit comment j'utilise mais en
toute chose je veux qu'on parle un peu
de technologie
ici à l'intérieur on va voir ce qu
oral-b nous appelle la technologie
magnétique et aux révolutionnaires
rien que ça on est six technologie qui
combine le mouvement à brens micro
vibrations sur la brosse et ronde
alimentée par le premier système de
traction magnétique alors j'en conviens
ça paraît un petit peu sorcier comme ça
en fait ce qu'il faut bien voir ici
c'est que vous avez des micro vibrations
ça ne tourne pas ça vibre en réalité
vous avez beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de micro vibrations
qui vont venir nettoyer efficacement vos
dents il vous permet de lutter contre la
plaque dentaire alors je ne suis pas un
spécialiste tout ce qui va être plaque
dentaire nettoyage de vos dents et
compagnie mais pour avoir essayé le
système je trouve très pratique et j'ai
en tout cas une sensation d'avoir des
dents propre et ça c'est plutôt agréable
alors il ya deux points qu'il vachement
intéressant c'est que vous avez un
système pour lutter contre les pressions
excessives mois avant lorsque
j'utilisais ma brosse manuelle fait
tendance à appuyer un petit peu trop du
coup j'avais souvent des petits
saignements au niveau des gencives
là par contre et ça c'est vachement
génial lorsque je viens a lancé j'ai la
couleur normale de magro ça donc j'ai
choisi je choisis la couleur si je
choisis d'être une autre couleur je peux
mettre une autre couleur je vais
vraiment la customiser la personnaliser
et quand je me rends s'est déroulée en
rouergue car c'est que c'est normal
couleur rouge qui a pu trop fort a eu à
pourvoir et à shawi un gage de confort
donc là ça me permettrait non c'est 10 à
parler comme ça dans les milieux comme
ça mais ça permet de savoir où est ce
que je suis au niveau de la pression
qu'ils exercent sur mes dents et bien
évidemment sur mes gencives
donc ça vient protéger les gens si les
sags à nettoyer efficacement il ya un
autre point qui est bien c'est que
lorsque je viens là lancé eh bien voyez
j'ai un petit chronomètre qui va se
lancer
ça me permet de savoir exactement où
j'en suis quand je me brosse les dents
et tout est trop seconde j'ai une double
vibrations pour savoir où j'en suis
comme ça vous êtes obligés de respecter
les règles je sais pas si vous êtes
parents mais moi qui suis papa toujours
en train de dire elliott deux minutes le
brossage de dents on a un petit sablier
ces deux minutes moi du coup je ne peux
pas faire moins de deux minutes s'il
fait moins de dix minutes je me sens pas
forcément très à l'aise dont bon voilà
je suis obligé de jouer le jeu et ça
c'est plutôt bien vu surtout c'est bien
pour mes dons et même pour la recharge
ici on est dans un produit technologique
puisque vous avez qu imposer votre
brosse à dents ici et elles devaient se
recharger directement en adduction vous
voyez votre niveau de charge qui monte
c'est plutôt bien vu et à noter qu'ici
la charge se fera en trois heures alors
on est sur une brosse à dents a besoin
que chose qui se charge très rapidement
il faut juste qu'ils soient prêtres au
moment où on aurait besoin
mais là où ils ont été également très
mal assez pour le recharger lorsque vous
partez en voyage ou si vous êtes un
nomade ou comme moi en temps normal vous
êtes beaucoup en hôtel en déplacement et
bien vous avez votre boîtier de
rechausser bien il vous suffit de
retirer votre petit bourg sainte que
vous venez poser et vous venez poser ici
votre brosse à dents qui va venir se
recharger en induction de la même
manière on a donc deux manières de venir
leur recharge et c'est très malin ses
pratiquants plus est complètement
sécurisé et hop là vous fermez ça se
recharge et en plus on a eu une led qui
nous indique la recharge est ensuite ou
bien ceux pilotés depuis votre
application oral b alors l'application
je trouve assez marrante je vais vous
montrer comment ça fonctionne en détail
lorsqu'on l'utilisent
vous allez voir vous allez venir vous
brossez ça vous expliquera les zones
couvertes ou pas vous pouvez lancer
votre brossage tout de suite vous pouvez
lancer des routines voir votre temps
d'utilisation de votre brosse est et à
quel moment la changer ici vous avez un
historique de votre brossage
je vois que j'ai un score moyen à 94
j'ai vraiment toutes les informations
notamment sur la couverture je vois que
règle générale je brosse assez bien
s'enfonçant à l'extérieur mais dans 100%
la mastication c'est la zone supérieure
des dents et 100 % à l'inter
autant vous dire que je pense que je
suis pas trop trop mauvais mais j'ai
également des informations concernant la
pression je vois sur quel dans et à quel
endroit j'ai eu trop de pression pendant
combien de temps mais également les
informations sur la durée moyenne et le
temps brossage sur le saignement des
gencives par des routines là c'est la
langue mais c'est également le fil
dentaire si je le souhaite
ou bien encore les bains de bouche donc
on voit qu'ici on relevait via pas
uniquement vous parlez de votre brossage
date leur brosse à dents elle vous
permet de mettre en place des routines
des bonnes pratiques pour l'hygiène
complète de vos dons mais là où ça
devient vraiment intéressant c'est que
vous avez un vrai reporting sur ce qui
s'est passé je vois qu'il ya par exemple
eh bien j'ai une durée de deux minutes
54 brossage non guidées le matin 2 0 de
brossage non guidés donc la gc quelques
informations là et surtout chez les
informations sur mon brossage d'idées au
lieu d'avoir une durée seulement
brossage d'idées et bien j'ai un score
je vois si j'ai été efficace score de 98
score de 96 c'est relativement différent
parce que si vous regardez un brossage
non guidées vous allez avoir le temps de
brossage vous allez avoir la pression
mais au-delà de ça pas grand chose
tandis que sur les résultats avec un
brossage guide et là c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est vraiment tout
l'intérêt qu'on va retrouver ici temps
de brossage 3,11 la couverture 100 % la
pression était ok j'ai bien brossés
toutes les zones de ma bouche
c'est la surface couverte la pression je
vois un tout petit peu ici mais vraiment
pas grand chose je vais vous montrer
dans quelques instants comment ça se
passe lorsque vous brosser les dents en
temps réel en brassage d'idées parce
qu'en fait c'est vraiment ça qui est
intéressant et ensuite vous avez des
petits les filles et la gamification
vous gagnez des petites médailles boyard
indien dingo là dessus mais c'est rigolo
la médaille de bienvenue la médaille
d'utilisation de la brosse à dents et
doit passer écrire dessus
je suis également superstar vous avez
ensuite accès à votre compte vous voyez
quand est ce que vous devrez remplacer
votre brosse êtes vous voyez l'âge de
votre brosse est la mienne et la 11
jours ça c'est intéressant si la
synchronisation des données de brossage
avec apple santé donc moi s'est connecté
mais différentes modifications
je vais donc vous montrer comment ça se
passe en cas concret pour avoir ici le
brossage évoluer directement ici là sur
mon application comme ça vous allez voir
le truc est vachement bien
je lance ma brosse à dents au lait bio
c'est l'extérieur des dans les lignes du
milieu c'est le dessus des dons et tout
ce qui à l'intérieur c'est l'intérieur
des dents je fais dehors là
et c'est encore un peu encore encore
encore aux taureaux le coq et
compression aura les compressions trouve
l'intérieur rien on voit ces bons
chronos devant là ils me demandent si
j'ai un saignement des gencives et
arrêté j'en ai pas tout va bien là je
vois bien n'a duré en zone couverte par
fait pression par contre j'ai inscrit au
passage de 88 je sais pas si c'est parce
que j'ai mis trop de pression par
endroits mais bon voilà c'est pas un
super super score brossé plus doucement
la prochaine fois et vous arrivez comme
ça j'ai livré conseille aussi de la part
de l'application je vous sens plutôt
bien
le prix de base est à 369 euros autant
vous dire que c'est pas une brosse à
dents qui va être destiné à tout le
monde c'est pas un produit pour tout le
monde c'est vraiment déjà d'une une
brosse à dents pour les personnes qui
veulent mettre ce budget dans leur
brosse à dents plutôt destiné aux
technophiles eu personne qui s'intéresse
vraiment à voir ce qui se passe moment
où elle se brosse les dents à voir ce
reporting vous avez une gamme qui est
très large vous avez beau coup de brosse
à dents électrique chez oral b celle là
c'est le produit d'exception pourquoi
s'adresse aux personnes qui veulent un
produit d'exception mais moi dans
l'ensemble c'est un produit xen bien que
je trouve très pratique je trouve très
malin et surtout l'idée de pouvoir
associer cette technologie ces nouvelles
technologies avec de l'intelligence
artificielle aux brosses à dents comment
est ce qu'on arrive à rendre un produit
d'hygiène comme la brosse à dents plus
intelligent plus efficient plus pratique
plus adaptées et personnalisées ont
relevé ici à relever le défi tout ça
bien une fois de plus un peu cher c'est
premium mes produits je trouve très
intéressant a vous de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire comment vous la trouvez
ces brosses à dents comment vous trouvez
ce produits connectés intelligents pour
la maison parce qu'il faut pas du tout
la réduire uniquement à une brosse à
dents celle usages se brosser les dents
se nettoyer les dents ce nettoyer les
langues
ces usages mais on entend un produit qui
est bien au delà de ça on reste dans
l'idée de l' objets connectés
intelligents pour la maison a vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on trouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer
par les textes parce que oui parce que
oui
l'ateq ne s'arrête pas à noël en
décembre en janvier toute l'année on est
assez bien beaucoup d'abord nous les
gros bisous et à très vite
[Musique]
m